l'histoire commence mercredi matin
dernier à regina en anglais justin
trudeau parle de son plan économique il
faut porter attention à trois
expressions utilisées mais d'autres
classes pour classes moyennes top dans
vers le bas et antoine à partir du coeur
justin trudeau s'est il inspiré de
barack obama
une phrase prononcée trois ans plus tôt
il ressemble beaucoup
est-ce que trudeau a volé une phrase
d'obama c'est la question posée le
lendemain sur youtube par une personne
dont on est incapable de vérifier
l'identité et qui met en ligne les deux
déclarations
les opposants ont réagi à la déclaration
de justin trudeau non pas sur sa
similitude avec celle d'obama mais sur
les mots utilisés tout gros 10 économies
from the heart was littéralement donc
faire croître l'économie à partir du
coeur le même jour dans l'après midi
thomas mulcair se moque de trudeau qu'on
peut faire croître l'économie avec des
slogans sentimentaux et en soirée
stephen harper en rajoute mais qu'est ce
que ça veut dire dit il de faire croître
l'économie à partir du coeur pour
conclure que ça veut juste dire que
trudeau n'est pas prêt à gouverner c'est
parti le toronto sun se moque de la
politique économique de trudeau qui part
du coeur en le dépeignant comme
calinours la presse reprend la
traduction littérale de la croissance
économique qui devrait partir du coeur
pour aussi se payer la tête de trudeau
ce mercredi à regina justin trudeau
at-il vraiment plagie barack obama elle
est là la différence barack obama a dit
l'économie qui croient à partir du coeur
de la classe moyenne
si trudeau avait plagié obama on aurait
peut-être mieux compris ce qu'il voulait
dire
maxence bilodeau réseau canada morrell
nous avons bien sûr demandé au parti
libéral de réagir voici ce qui nous a
fait parvenir
monsieur trudeau fait campagne contre un
plan économique qui a échoué
ce thème a souvent été soulevée par
barack obama dans le passé
la classe moyenne est le moteur de nos
économies nous parti libéral est le seul
parti à demander aux plus riches
dentaire un peu plus pour qu'on puisse
baisser les impôts de la classe moyenne